[Musique]
comment ce qu on devient bande
dessinateur bof c'est passé comme ça si
tu veux j'aurais pu faire de
l'illustration j'ai démarché avec un dos
et d'illustrations bon ça n'a rien donné
j'ai essayé de faire de cartoon ou six a
rien donné non plus au fait du dessin
humoristique et j'ai fait après de la
bande dessinée et ça a marché à l'or
mais si c'était si ç'avait
d'illustration que le marché je serais
devenu illustratrice est-ce que tu pars
d'habitude du nid des textes ou des
images l'unité de take two tu écris
j'écris oui j'ai créé entièrement le
dialogue et après ça je fais mes carrés
ce qui m'intéresse c'est laisser les
dialogues et les dialogues ou les trials
conversation entre les gens et pour les
faire parler il faut les asseoir quelque
part où il fallait mettre dans des
conditions où les gens parlent
habituellement les gens parlent quand
ils ont à la fin du repas ou quand ils
prennent un point clé quand ils prennent
le thé quand ils prennent un whisky ou
godefroy d'un café où tu vois bon donc
je dessine comme ça et c'est toujours
les mêmes genres c'est toujours la même
catégorie duo oui oui la même catégorie
comment est ce que tu t'es fixé sur
cette catégorie de gens parce que c'est
cette catégorie de gens qui se veulent
intellectuelle libéré de gauche et et
vivent bien étant sûr de détenir la
vérité praticables ce qu'analysent
trouvant des solutions à tous et caetera
et qui sont constamment contradiction
avec avec eux mêmes et ça donne des
résultats intéressants sous je suis moi
akale typiques de ce genre de chant il
fait beaucoup de brouillon oui je fais
beaucoup de bruit c'est pas d'un premier
jet non pas du tout c'est très léché tu
peux me parler entre eux dans ce groupe
pourquoi on a critiqué de faire un
tonneau mais je suis on dit souvent que
le texte est très est très soignée et
puis ça fait contraste avec un dessin on
me dit enlevés pour être gentil mais ça
veut dire dors chez toi et ça me rend
furieuse parce que je sois énorme parce
que je passe beaucoup de temps à ce que
ça a l'air spontanée il est en rapport
avec les problèmes des femmes là mais
l'afld est ce que tu en fais partie je
veux pas partie de mes lèvres enfin le
féminisme c'est vraiment à la seule
chose qui m'intéresse en soit en ce
moment je peux dire mais c'est assez
difficile parce que moi le mini le
militantisme j'ai horreur de ça parce
que dans le militantisme ya ce côté pur
et dur il ya les gens qui sont sûrs
d'avoir raison qui vont contre le mal
qui est certainement le mal sans
discussion possible
moi ça m'emmerde beaucoup comme attitude
et d'autre part cité féministe tué
pratiquement obligé de prendre une
attitude de martyrs du objets tout
expliquer expliquer tout échec par le
fait qu'on a empêché de que ceux-ci que
cela alors ça moi ça m'emmerde également
donc je peux pas avoir une attitude
féministe franche et comme de toute
façon dans n'importe quel domaine je
trouve qu'on arrive à ses fins qu en
biaisant et quand elle en parle à bander
en étant un maximum hypocrite dans ce
domaine là je trouve que c'est aussi la
meilleure
meilleur système c'est à dire si tu veux
je fais acte de féminisme est en fait un
an mettant des femmes là où autrefois
hommes et à des hommes dans la bande
dessinée il y avait que deux types de
femmes y avait ou la pp gironde où là où
la mégère vraiment que ça dans l'essai
memory stick aussi moi je mets des gens
fille normale et courante et qui sont ni
l'un ni l'autre ni giron ni pépé giron
ni mégère on avait dit on en a marre de
s'auto censurer ou d'être censuré et là
on se laisse aller bon ben je trouve que
c'est infiniment plus difficile si tu
veux la censure engendre des idées ne
serait ce que pour la contourner
donc pour toi des sujets scatologique ou
pornographique sont absolument pas le
domaine qui t'intéresse mais si ça
m'intéresse beaucoup mais par la bande
[Rires]
[Musique]